i have not gotten my period in a little
while
and i was supposed to get it like last
week so i kind of got nervous and like
randomly took a test
yeah and it came back positive kendall
jenner pulled off some
major pranks on her famous family during
a game of truth or dare with her sister
kourtney kardashian for court's
lifestyle site
push oh my god just be cool it's fine
the 25 year old model's first victim
her momager kris jenner calm mom and
tell her you're pregnant
oh yeah she went there so i have a
scenario
okay i have not gotten my period
in a little while and i was supposed to
get it like last week so i
kind of got nervous and like randomly
took a test yeah
and it came back positive so i took
another one
and that one also came back positive and
i'm literally like
about to cry it's worth pointing out
kendall is the only one of the six
siblings who doesn't have children
that's so weird you just told me this
because i dreamed about this last night
really really really really crazy i'm
kind of freaking out i just like don't
know what to do
um well i'll put on my clothes and get
over there
[Music]
well i'll tell you kendall uh what
you know you have to do whatever your
heart tells you to do
i think it's great news but i'm your mom
you know
i mean kendall did a pretty good job
because chris seemed to buy it
even with all that giggling mom i'm just
kidding
mom
mom i'm with corey she's
just kidding mom relax
all right well i love you and i loved
your reaction
oh brother all right okay they'll put
the champagne back
on ice okay but it didn't stop there
text our family group chat that you just
got engaged oh my gosh
kendall is currently dating nba star
devin booker
and e.t recently learned the two are
getting pretty serious
but it's believable so i will do it okay
does anyone have a wedding ring
yeah and she did they love it kendall
borrowed a ring from someone on set
and sent a pic to the fam group chat
which was immediately met with a
facetime from her sister kylie jenner
hi no kendall you're live
we're playing truth or dare and that was
her dare
she text everybody yeah but play into it
play into it
first of all it doesn't fit you well it
needs to be
signed hold on i'm answering kim yeah
and her sister kim kardashian
she wasn't buying it either
[Applause]
as for chloe well she didn't hold back
her thoughts on the prank
that's so stupid why would you do that
to me
i was just disappointed it was a little
big on your finger
okay so she's not engaged yet but while
kendall is usually
super private about her love life a
source previously told et
that quote she's really happy with her
relationship with devin
and doesn't care who knows and when it
comes to courtney
she and boyfriend travis barker seem to
be all in
such a dream come true the pair has
recently taken trips together
visiting the snow and the desert and
source tells et the blink 182 rocker is
so in love and
infatuated with the push founder he's
100
all in and totally sees a future with
her courtney is living her best
life and is truly so happy cheers
to both couples being happy in love